it was quieter as much as they didn't even think that it
would happen again
[music]
no one was hurt just acquaintances it's the same
store we all know the
woman
It's a pity I only saw them in the morning they didn't
come
tell me around 9 a.m. Today there was a
blow, it was previously hung up on which
police specialist It was  the S300 missile was
launched from the
Belgorod region of the Russian
Federation. As you can see, it hit a
place
where citizens are generally located. Where
was the market, where there are always
regular residents, where there is no
military object, no military
target, this strike did not take place at the
present time, we can  to ascertain the
presence of seven victims, two of whom
are two women, unfortunately, one woman died, one woman fell
under Zavaliv, the
State Emergency Service together with the police, another woman has already
died.
in order to cause
as much damage as possible to the city  ir people to
force them to leave their homes to force them to
be in a panic
people were passing by and were
injured
We live near the market and earth fell on us
we realized what it was
Something flew somewhere we ran to find out
what you are like because we live right on the
house Earth fell